[Música]
vamos a hablar de economía en directo
américa ya sea conmigo en el estudio
àngel hablando daniela bienvenida feliz
miércoles es para ti vamos a hablar por
supuesto como lo adelantábamos además de
facebook en el ojo del huracán pero sin
embargo se recupere unas bolsas daniela
hola raúl buenos días de nuevo pues mire
en facebook o volvió a ser protagonista
como ya sabemos en el senado esta vez no
por temas de competencia como siempre
suele hacerlo sino por este tema de la
denuncia que hace una ex empleada pues
en francesa joven hizo un retrato
despiadado bastante de la empresa
diciendo que ocultaba información al
público y que sus plataformas son
nocivas y priorizan los beneficios por
encima del bienestar de las personas a
lo que su propio fundador mark
zuckerberg respondió que esto no es
cierto así este nivel pero ahora
entonces repasemos las cifras bueno pues
el marcador reaccionó a favor de la red
social raúl después de haber caído casi
un 5 por ciento en la víspera facebook
que se recuperó aunque a medias porque
había caído un 5 por ciento cerró con
ganancias de alrededor del 2 por ciento
como también lo hicieron las otras
tecnológicas ahora veamos las cifras
financieras raúl si le parece en 2020
miles esta empresa generó ingresos por
casi 86 mil millones de dólares la gran
mayoría de ellos proviene de los
anunciantes de ese total alrededor de
una tercera parte como vemos son
utilidades 29 mil 146 millones en este
caso 58 por ciento frente de subida
frente al año anterior y tiene mil 840
millones de usuarios activos
daniela ahora los países ricos dan pasos
agigantados para gravar a las
multinacionales
bueno pues los ministros de finanzas de
la organización para el desarrollo para
la cooperación en desarrollo económicos
que es la ocde también conocida como el
club de países ricos están para reunirse
el viernes de manera virtual y aprobar
eventualmente una tarifa del 15% para
las grandes multinacionales se trata
raúl de una propuesta que lleva varios
meses en discusión y que pretende
desincentivar el uso de paraísos
fiscales por parte de las compañías el
objetivo es que sea respaldada por el
g20 a finales de este mes hasta ahora
134 de los 140 países involucrados en
las negociaciones lo apoyan el ministro
de finanzas francés blue bruno le maire
lo resumió de la siguiente manera
estamos a un milímetro de un acuerdo
global pero irlanda donde se encuentran
muchas multinacionales debido a sus
bajas tasas impositivas se ha negado a
participar y dice que sólo lo aceptaría
si hacen cambios en la iniciativa por
ejemplo incluir salvaguardas para que no
se eleve de nuevo este gravamen en un
futuro cercano
daniela hay algo que yo no entiendo qué
pasa en la india- y gracias a dios usted
está aquí para que me lo explique porque
ya en dos estados de ese país tener una
silla en el trabajo
la gente trabaja de pie no entiendo así
como usted lo está diciendo miren muchos
países del mundo los trabajadores de las
tiendas minoristas están de pie casi
todo el día no solamente en la india y
estoy segura que en américa latina pues
también ese es un problema muy grave las
ventas minoristas en india representan
el 10 por ciento del pib nacional y
emplean al 8% de su fuerza laboral la
mayoría de ellas mujeres en un país de
1400 millones de habitantes entonces
también en nada se convirtió en el
segundo estado de india en consagrar el
derecho a sentarse en la ley así como
luego ya después de su vecino que era la
citando problemas en la salud como
artritis entre otros la norma obliga a
los dueños también a que les permitan a
los trabajadores tomarse descansos
durante la jornada laboral pero no poder
sentarse es apenas una de las
dificultades diarias que enfrentan
quienes viven de esta industria los
sindicatos hablan de que reciben bajos
salarios y que a veces tienen que
trabajar los siete días de la semana
como le parece
pero si usted está ahí cansada porque
está de pie a su siguiente once daniela
indica
en asia persisten las incertidumbres por
supuesto por el grande el principal
índice de la bolsa de hong kong cayó en
0,57 por ciento a la espera de que se
concrete la posible venta de una de las
subsidiarias de este grupo inmobiliario
y también hubo grandes pérdidas en
europa después de que el alza en los
precios del petróleo alcanzará máximos
de varios años y le tengo una noticia de
bolsa la familia glazer que son los
dueños del manchester united sacarán a
la venta en bolsa 18 por ciento de su
participación en el club ahora quedarán
con el 69% y que nos traerá como cifra
el día daniela pues precisamente
hablando de petróleo el precio de crudo
de la opep superó los 80 dólares por
barril por primera vez desde el 10 de
octubre de 2018 esta es una canasta de
13 calidades de crudo que se usa como
referencia para la venta de sus países
miembros y está muy ligada a otras
referencias y la razón que la opep no
quiso subir
en producción de cruz pues tener las
gracias por toda la información
económica nos vemos más adelante con el
segundo bloque de economía en directo
américa